muchas sigue buscando a sus muertos
mientras el presidente ruso vladimir
putin otorgaba vía decreto un título
honorífico a la brigada acusada por las
autoridades ucranianas de estar detrás
de la muerte de civiles en esta urbe
cerca de kiev no todas las familias han
podido recuperar los cuerpos de sus
seres queridos pese a que moscú ha
negado los asesinatos de civiles tras el
retiro de las tropas del kremlin se
recolectaron evidencias de las muertes
de centenares de personas
netflix isl y la gente enterrada
personas en sus huertos en sus jardines
alrededor de sus casas después de la
liberación de butch a la gente llamó la
policía vino el grupo de investigación
los empleados de los servicios
municipales retiraron los cuerpos la
policía hizo los informes y se llevaron
los cuerpos a la morgue donde los
expertos forenses y los investigadores
trabajaron en ellos y comprobó el psuv
mente experta y de curso y chip las
autoridades ucranianas han cifrado en
400 el balance de víctimas mortales en
lucha entre ellas está el marido de
nadie a quien sólo ahora ha tenido el
acceso a enterrar a su esposo
llamé y me dijeron que estaba allí me
dijeron bill a ser guapo voy arca o
visor según el espacio que haya en las
cámaras frigoríficas
y hoy he venido y me han dicho que el
cuerpo estaba listo para ser enterrado
como murió de un disparo en la cabeza
chrome ya iba de camino al supermercado
y yo imagino que lo sacaron de casa
porque las papas estaban peladas las
cebollas estaban peladas
en la corte penal internacional dijo que
investigaría a lo ocurrido en lucha como
crímenes de guerra no obstante para
algunas familias allí lo esencial ahora
es encontrar los cuerpos de sus padres
hermanos o hijos y darles descanso